don't you think it's insane in a way to
go to a foreign country and somehow send
a tape to a network and say listen i'm
here anyway so i'm going to act i'm
going to pretend it was a scheme
basically i i i worked as a i got a job
finally i couldn't get a job at abc i
finally got a part-time job as a
fact-checker at this thing called
channel one which is show seen in high
schools throughout america about half
the schools in america and the time
right and um imagine you go to yale and
then you're a fact tracker so i did that
for like five months right and then i
realized okay i came up with this idea
of like i'm going to
this is not working i got i'm going to
go start going to wars it's something i
feel personally about i i feel depressed
i want to i want to go these places i
want to see things i want i want an
interesting and how did you finance this
well that's the
uh
modeling money i'm not i'm not modeling
right now
mom wasn't gonna pay for it no my mom
paid for up to college and that was it
that was the deal um but but i could i
could live in africa for five dollars a
day i was living in burma for nothing
and it's weird when you decide to go to
a war it's like it's not so apparent how
you walk into a war yeah it's it's not
that hard though i mean you just yeah
and a lot of these i mean like in burma
there's not a lot of reporters like at
the time were bullets whizzing by your
head in the house
in burma there were you know mortars
going off yeah when you were over at
these dangerous situations in these
countries did you videotape yourself
yeah i uh well i figured i i have to
have a reason to go i can't just like be
a like a war taurus so um yeah i made a
fake press pass and i borrowed a camera
and i started i snuck into burma and
hooked up some students fighting the
burmese government and who tapes you who
video i would shoot myself i would take
myself i would turn the camera around
yeah and then sometimes like in somalia
because there were so many gunmen
walking around you would hire your own
gunman and then sometimes i would say to
them like can you put the ak down and
just hold the camera so i can do a stand
up do you miss the action at all no i
still do it all the time you know i
still go for cnn but it's not the same
when you go for cnn it's a little less
well it's different now just because i'm
i'm more recognizable so there's like
more there's security involved and it's
you know uh and it it's it's actually
more dangerous now it's far more
dangerous than it was back then
um but it's uh but i know i and who do
you send these tapes to that takes
notice and starts using them well so i
had this since i had a relationship with
channel one i said to channel one i'm
quitting i'm going to wars um and
you know i'll show you the videos and if
you like them you can put them on and
it'll cost i don't know a thousand
dollars per store i just made up some
figure right and uh they were like well
okay because i knew if i said to them
will you send me they'll be like no
we're not going to send you it's
dangerous you don't even know you have
no experience we're not going to do it
but i i just made it impossible for them
not to at least look at the tape so you
send this to channel one they start
airing these right and then who picks up
on that well that's that's uh so they
they're the burma stuff and then i'm
like hoping they're like oh this is
incredible we're gonna offer your job
they don't so then i say okay well now
i'm gonna go to africa i'm going to go
to africa for six months i guarantee you
ten stories here are the ten stories and
so they made a deal with me they're like
okay fine go to africa for six months
here there are the ten stories and the
first one i did was in somalia in the
early days of a famine in august of 92
and uh it was really dramatic stuff it
was really and um it had been there with
your own camera taking pictures and
doing all that there were a thousand
people dying a day in somalia from
famine there was you know fighting going
on and and i was getting you know and i
ma i did a really poignant story and it
had a really big impact on the child
went audience school started to raise
money for somalia relief you will step
in if you see something going on it's
not like you just kind of uh did not
associate with anybody yeah i mean i it
depends on the situation but yes like in
haiti uh i there was a kid after the
earthquake we're the first team on the
ground i spent a month there for cnn
there was a kid we were in a riot and a
kid
somebody threw a cement brick onto a
kid's head and split open why did they
do that they were attacking the kid no
they were
it was like the it's a long story but
they were basically trying to disperse a
crowd from and so one of the so so one
of the authorities no it was just some
some some like bandit guy just took a
cement block and threw it into the crowd
and he cracked open this kid's head and
what did you do
honestly i started running toward it
thinking i was going to take a picture
because everyone ran away from this kid
and this kid had blood pouring out of
his head and he was his eyes were
rolling back his head and he just played
11 10 11 years old and i i took two
steps and i was like i'm not going to
videotape this it's horrible i didn't
right so i grabbed the kid and just i
brought him back you're a hero no that's
a heroic thing
i gotta tell you i'd be scared i'd [ __ ]
my pants if i was in a riot and people
are starting to throw stones and crack
people's heads open i probably would run
the other way but that's the kind of man
that's not true you never know how
you're going to react i know how i react
i'm pretty sure i know
we've seen him in a crisis oh maybe
robin has seen me when she goes you
should step in and go oh please don't
fail me now